- These look like glory holes.
(upbeat music)
- I spend about about $150 for my haircut.
- 20 bucks.
- I don't really show my
hair for the most part,
so I don't need to spend much.
- 40, 50 dollars?
- I have a feeling I'll be good at telling
which haircut is more expensive.
- Yeah, I think I'm gonna be really good
at judging people's hair.
- Absolutely not.
- I'm ready to try.
- All in.
Were you glad I washed my hair?
(laughs)
- Can you turn your head
to the left, both of you,
so I can see the sides, now to the right.
- They have the sides tapered around
and then it transitions
into like this fuo qua.
- This one looks like a more
precise job like in the back.
So I'm gonna say that
this is the expensive one,
and this is the cheap one.
- [Producer] You are wrong.
- Dammit.
- Less expensive, this
is the more expensive.
- [Producer] Right.
- We got lucky on this one.
(laughs)
- This is the expensive
haircut, right here.
This is the cheaper haircut.
- [Producer] Right.
- I am?
- Opa!
- This is the more expensive one.
And this is the less expensive one.
- [Producer] You were right.
(shouts)
- It's the layers.
- My hair is $30.
- Without color, mine is $50.
- You should go to his guy.
(bell dings)
- You kinda have like bangs in the front.
- Kind of bangs, yeah.
- Hair smells like Pantene.
- If anybody's hair is
over $100, I'm screaming.
(laughs)
- I think because of the double layer,
that that's more work.
- Did they cut your ends?
- They cut my ends.
- Oh they f--ked up.
- This haircut is the
more expensive haircut,
and this haircut is the cheap haircut.
- [Producer] You are wrong.
- What?
(laughs)
- More expensive, less expensive.
- [Producer] Wrong.
- I believe this is the
more expensive haircut,
and this is the cheaper haircut.
- [Producer] Wrong.
- Okay, I had to get one wrong.
- More expensive, barely.
This one is less expensive.
- [Producer] Wrong.
- Mine was $100.
- You know how many tanks
of gas that would fill?
- $25.
I have a theory that
the Santa Monica Supercuts
is the best Supercuts.
The person who dog sits
for Jennifer Lawrence
gets her hair cut there.
- What?
(bell dings)
- Come, my little angels.
- Yours is very styled, nice and short.
- This is like a very Beatles haircut.
- You know, your hair reminds me
of Harry Styles, the One Direction guy.
- Thank you!
- I'm really jealous of
your bangs situation.
- I'm gonna sniff now.
- His is more expensive
cause I want his hair.
- [Producer] Right.
- Yay, oh, I am good at the boy ones now.
- More expensive, less expensive.
- [Producer] Wrong.
- This one looks like the
more expensive haircut to me,
and this one looks like
the cheaper haircut.
(dings)
- This is the more expensive
one, this is the cheaper one.
- [Producer] You were right.
(shouts)
- It's the layers that are expensive.
- 95.
- Mine was 20.
- S--t! Sorry, excuse my language. Man!
That's like a week's
worth of groceries for me.
- I spent $20.
- Oh, I got it, I said
it at the same time!
Did you see that?
(bell dings)
- So, I'm gonna just
pet the hair real quick
to see which one's softer.
- I feel like I'm looking at wigs.
- Is this considered layered?
- Um, yes.
- Both your haircuts kinda look the same.
- Okay, your hair smells really good.
Your hair smells good but
like Whole Foods good.
- More expensive, less expensive.
- [Producer] Wrong.
- Her haircut is the more expensive,
and hers is the cheap haircut.
- [Producer] Right.
- Yay!
- This one is the more expensive haircut,
and this one is the cheaper haircut.
- [Producer] Correct.
- That's cool.
- Her hair is more expensive
cause it's coarser.
I feel like her hair is less expensive
because her hair is not coarse.
- [Producer] Wrong.
(shouts)
- Mine was $8.
- Wow!
- Woah!
- Cheaper than McDonald's.
- Mine was $150.
- Ooh, they robbed you girl!
(bell dings)
- This was trickier than
I thought it would be.
- For those who are spending
triple digit and near triple digit,
I would take a long walk on the beach,
and rethink some of the
priorities in their life.
- One of my favorite haircuts was the girl
who got it done at Supercuts.
- $5 Uber pool, go over to Korea Town,
go over to South Central,
and get your hair cut there.
Cause you're being fleeced,
you're walking into these salons
and they're like, hands
up, it's a stickup.
- As long as it looks good on you,
it doesn't matter if you spend
a lot of money on your hair.
- Was gel included?
- The styling gel.